all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 84 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about a special
guest so we're gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord who is not
only considered a genuine friends in the
realm but it's always a pleasure to
cross paths with and each and every
press event and gaming convention this
Lord exemplifies the definition of true
gaming passion is one of the hardest
workers in the business yet always
exudes consistent professionalism with
any Lord he comes in contact with
introducing the United States community
manager for warhorse studios and PR for
the narrative award-winning Kingdom Come
deliverance franchise the Lord of all
things Bohemia and one of the very first
Lords to rock the ILP t-shirt but the
utmost way
baking his debut its the realm of the
Lord's mahmud Lord Rick let me see how
you doing sir
okay let's go
absolute plan to have you in the room
you are a lord at what you do and it's
only right we had you here at the realm
of the Lord's way are you ready have
some fun oh we're already
[Laughter]
so happy to have you been long overdue
absolutely Edie of course you know we
have the Four Horsemen of gaming don't
serve these new Lords of the realm here
at the round table my co-host with the
co most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good
[Music]
you don't want to
[Laughter]
eat chili that gotta do yeah I see you
place inner-city sex face yeah beat
Center I actually beat it twice
saluted of that I
reviewed it not beat dia well I
apparently I didn't know this but now I
if you banish all the sins you actually
have a different final boss I didn't
know that so yes guys go through there
and find out how to banish every
individual sin so I can fight the secret
lies boss no doubt that's that's even if
that's real who knows I'll probably do
it no BGR joint role
in demon looks like those guys are doing
well hit game pass as well so salute
what is it sinner sacrifice Redemption
the full name
yes big announcement this week they are
in
packs very you're acting like you don't
play that
that game is directly up your alley and
I'm not gonna disrespect your talents
when it comes to that because that was
seriously and you've gone through that
game was incredible but for people that
like that type of game that game is
serious and for it to be in game pass I
think that's that's huge that's huge is
amazing so yeah oh oh Rick's attention
is up
telematics
Center sacrified emption I hate saying
Dark Souls clone cuz it's not you know
it's got that that gameplay I think
that's what most people say when they
you know say darks us clothes got that
gameplay from Dark Souls because they
kind of like started their own genre
with dark so it it's got that kind of
gameplay but the difference is it's you
know it's just a boss rush for you only
fight the bosses and every time you
fight a boss you actually have to
sacrifice something on you from like a
tributes to your hell to your shield and
when you beat the boss you get you get
you have to redeem that you beat the
boss you get health but you don't get
what you originally sacrificed back so
if they're you're giving up you start
off powerful and you kind of you start
out the strongest you'll get you get
weaker from every boss that is sick
crazy I like like when I fought the last
boss I had a lot of help and what's
funny is you get more health but that's
kind of useless because you they take
like half your health when they hit you
on this game so
I saw what he was doing I was cheering
them on it was incredible so but it may
have more it may have your attention
you have to do you have to switch back
and forth between the the two-handed
sword and the and the sword and the
shield so you could just pick one you
could just use one I switch back and
forth cuz certain bosses are easier to
use the shield with than others when you
fight lust she because they're all based
off of the seven deadly sins it's like
the worst people in history have been
reincarnated and the seven deadly sins
and when you play love she uh she's
really fast but if you know shield
compared you're a lot easier and then
when you take her health down to zero if
you don't kill her before she does her
transformation you have to fight a giant
worm Wow so you know that can get really
good the first time I did it I killed
her before she transformed mhm and so I
thought it was easy well what I did it
the second time I realized what how did
I do it because it wasn't easy
once or twice as she would almost be
dead then she would just transform I
think what I did is I caught my sword on
fire the first time so I did more damage
I think that's what I did but
you know there are no sovereign you know
we walking away from the game and he's
like looking back at the game like he
like he left a piece of his
coat vein I almost beat that boss and
that because I gotta wait till next year
no you don't even know like I had
everyone around the area behind me
because that dude was almost dead only
like six people beat at the entire the
entire time shout out to those guys
Bandai Namco Dimitri and
I was going at him and I liked it and I
ran out of stamina and I started like
you know breathing good stuff instead of
hitting them and it literally back to he
backed up he looked at me and he just he
just slapped me
shut out the punch he said a watch
addict play he was raging on that game
no doubt of course we have our most
technical gaming
experience
of the
game is
so what else you been playing so would
you meet everything math still haven't
gone come back to Tomb Raider which is
you know
but I'll get
the Assassin's Creed Odyssey been
playing a lot of that been playing a lot
of the Forza horizon I don't see is a no
events man in Forza man every single
season feels so distinct the terrain
feels so distinct like it feels like
four separate games every time the
season changes it's crazy yeah it is
that the level of Paulist in that game
is sort of nuts
when I picked up Sinha for the switch I
only played I got up to the further half
a frame rate
the portability and it didn't work out
for
the PlayStation has the same issues but
the Xbox
pretty much yeah I'm surprised you did
it because Kai bots who wanted me to do
it I'm like look man they just announced
game pass that's kind of like a
3/3 actually famous which ran five
like what world does Chabad to see when
he plays switch games because it must be
it must be it's like you just took Joy
on we happy few because
there's always an eternal debate here at
the roundtable farce widget
because we always
talk to
switch is the fact that they try to
force the shoe and stuff to dismiss
cannot move on the switch
[Music]
like Big Brother
does it
[Music]
[Laughter]
come deliverance on there you'll be like
I have to have a conversation about
this galets in the chat good to see you
bro
alright and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
oh
the lord of combat sports who is a man
of his convictions the man's nothing
less than that premium experience and is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
Oh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir we
are doing
today listen um my man Rick is here and
this is a great job to talk about man
stuff all right I'm hitting this fraud
right now and we're gonna talk about man
stuff real quick let's get all right I
surround myself with these lords and
these Lords or men
all right we're not when I'm talking
about men
exactly that that's that's the whole
thing with stand-up individuals with
people that uh that we give you our word
and our word as our born when you come
into this world you come into this world
naked with your voice and that carries
alright say smack you on the butt to
hear your voice to know that you are
here to make your presence felt okay and
in this
that carries alright so when you give
somebody you're born when you look at
them in the eyes and you shake their
hands and you call someone friend or you
invite them into your clan as a man or
woman you expect this to be a certain
level of respect now Oh
guys that have been in our destiny clan
our iron lord destiny clan I've told you
guys come over come one come all we
welcome all welcome you casually work on
the hard call we welcome
if you haven't been playing
community and we're looking to help
people and get helped and everything
each one teach one you understand the
realm is open to all now I got a call
for myself in the same scenario as
Cognito is like let's say he's the owner
of the clan right so let's say I don't
think that's the scenario he is the
owner
understand what I'm about to say I am
the the manager GM you're the chance a
hashtag man stuff this is hilarious
right I could do this yo y'all y'all
about the lotta stuff right here so as
the manager GM and running a team you
select people you bring people over and
you see how it fits with your team now
I've always heard this before
why certain GM's and managers won't add
certain people to their team because of
my poison the group you understand no
they might have a supreme talent
anything great at one thing or something
and they might bring something to the
table but winning at every course at all
costs sometimes it's not a win at all is
alone
and you make concessions for these
people so as a GM I lusted over an
individual named tak to bring him over
to the clan because with this individual
I cleared raids I cleared hard night
falls yes and he's the supreme talent
but also he's the person that who's full
of himself hmmm alright but when he's oh
he's alone he's a nice individual now
that comes with warts his walk is a
player named hardcore now hardcore is an
individual who doesn't have the same
amount of talent as TAC he may think he
does and
he's a very bitter individual now that
when those two individuals get together
he spoils how TAC is because tank
becomes a different person so she's now
on these are in his squad he also has a
rest of his team which is Dino ensue and
they they are good people these two
people are really good people and
talking to the clan once these people
defected from the clan the people that
they miss the most is Dino Dino is a
very nice dude very very warm
he's a good guy now
I'm not talking from my standpoint of
bitterness I'm talking from a standpoint
of being a man if I open my door to you
you did not leave my door open at night
and sneak out the back door
like a coward
you as a man you have the respect as a
man you lose respect as a man if you
walk out see because I never knew that
they left the clan if you leave you to
tell me yo I'm leaving it's fine
open-door policy have a nice day it's
cool but while you was there you were
berating of the clans mate saying that
they were trash they were good and
bye-bye bringing you in I understand now
what it means winning at any cost is not
a win
so
getting the 600 at any cost without
bringing up the rest of your clan mates
I wasn't 600 because I was helping my
clan mate monkey Lord monkey get his
level up oh I was helping Lord Cole and
I noticed that certain individuals that
I was playing what before you showed up
weren't coming around anymore
because they didn't like your vernacular
a disturbance in the flow you were there
exactly
so and I'm talking to all the clans
mates after you're gone
99% of them a happy you left
100% of happy there hall cause gone mmm
so you won't be miss but I'm gonna give
you some part in knowledge because I
know your boy listens
bed the next time you go someplace else
you walk in as a man you leave as a man
because that's how you'll be remembered
then this world you come in with only
your word and you're born and if you do
not live up to that you are nothing how
many night falls you don't clear okay
how many rage you don't clear if you're
not a man you can't stand on your ones
and your tools you are absolutely
nothing in this world and so these men
that I sit with here this is family and
we can walk anywhere what I heads up
high because everybody that knows us
know that we are stand-up individuals
you have my phone number you could have
called and said I'm out you are sucker
and that's exactly what you'll be known
as until you talk to me as a man yo sir
Schuyler said oh my god this man talking
[Laughter]
motivational kingdom come deliver
instead because that game does not hold
your hand and you must grow from a boy
[Laughter]
right so let me tell you something um I
was playing Kingdom Come deliverance on
pc i was playing um forza
destiny that did oh that the haunted
forest is fantastic I got the gun the
horror story and I'm also on my man
laughs its inquest right now I'm playing
a little bit of spider-man here in there
um so that was my week but that Kingdom
Come deliverance brother I was like is
that couldn't be a fraud I couldn't talk
to you you face you don't be affordable
I go you play your game
guess no yo
system
probably one of the most ga'head man to
figure it out
it's probably the truest RPG in essence
like everything it's a survival game
it's a right is an RPG like all that
old-school j.r produced oh that's
nothing a peasant is
this is the real deal
I mean you know Henry's amateur
something trouble and I always got stuff
to do and he's like oh shoot how do you
do this
blacksmith doesn't mean you know use a
sword so you got to learn everything so
it's great when you see people playing
on Twitch and they think they're like
mr. tough guy and they're all
I didn't know how to quit swords and
stuff and I had that sword that my dad
made but I'm like all right I thought it
was just like a quest item or something
because I couldn't figure out how to get
it out alright and I come up on this
dude and he's got a dagger or something
and I'm like so I guess I guess but I'm
being a boxing match and you got a
dagger okay
out boxes dude before he killed me with
that deck my choice is run
even your run wasn't right at the
beginning of the game that you had to
figure out how to get
the dishonorable kills that one people
like screw this they took they're born
to shot
[Laughter]
and of course thank you for the previous
play and of we have the gaming themself
the shinobi Lord Cognito spending that
realness in the realm of the ILP now
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so very similar
the King just a little bit of Destiny
low iron banner actually uh this is the
police - as well still continuing my
story with that crazy game and of course
I had to start that new playthrough of
Kingdom Come deliverance start all over
from the beginning with the both DLCs I
wanted a fresh experience so I'm just
getting out of getting that going and
yeah man that's pretty much it on the
game in front but um we have to do a
state in the realm as well so hear ye
hear ye with the very special spin in
them so obviously as most of you are
here already already know and on Twitter
the Lords will now be doing our live
shows on the Isle or podcast YouTube
channel 2018 was a very very special
year for us and we are truly proud of so
many things were able to accomplish and
it's more small time we got a ton of
things playing Joe and it wouldn't be
right though not to thank our brothers
over at the inner circle Network the
affiliates the entire writing staff back
to games Network comm for believing in
our vision giving us a tremendous
opportunity and getting a chance to work
alongside all of them over the years so
I am Lord salut
still look forward to seeing each and
every one of you in the round you know
so uh now that we got all the love out
the way and with the Lords of playing I
want to start with Rick and here's a
video game system history his journey to
becoming the community manager of
warhorse Studios and our chief PR
representative for the award-winning
Kingdom Come deliverance franchise so
Lord right let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had in like what
got you the gaming the the first one was
actually technically my grandfather got
it for all the odds grandkids for
Christmas it was an Atari man eight
eight seven eighty six hundred I don't
know probably 26 let's go it was the
first game was the dunk you know Mario
Donkey Kong game of course right
and then from there was Mario Luigi game
you know a little couch co-op you know
what else we got that was that racing it
wasn't racing game man I love those
in pole position
there was no pole position this [ __ ] and
they in that just 826 I mean that was
the game and I don't even play many
racing games but I played it I played
this Mike I love 100 it's
this baseball game you know what I mean
like that once I got into that man it
was over you know anything my
grandfather's house I mean they'd be
owned there's what's all that noise down
there because we'd be sleeping
downstairs you know
1 2 in the morning
[Laughter]
so then then from there you know went to
I was always Nintendo man there's
console wars were all the way back to
Nintendo and Sega man you know
so what we smoke some Soraka I got a
slowly back of it so being the console
was as we know right the back then was
pretty even at Ed's back they're like
how did you survive the the genesis does
what Nintendo error how did you survive
that when Sega was coming on strong with
that Genesis it's the same thing as
always man the games because I was good
I was good with Nintendo because you
know back then though you got one good
game like twice a year yeah
max and it wasn't that there was you
know bad games have just that this it
took them longer right I mean or just
you know there wasn't as much of a
demand or whatever you know but I mean
sure you play you know you got your
Zelda's and the Mario's the donkey cause
I mean that that's right I mean I was I
was good and because you know back then
two men we didn't game as much as we did
today like I was outdoors playing gun
games and you know you know a truth bomb
and drive him out my bookbag after
school so I was doing all that but at
the same time if we had all these games
and then I'd you know
oh
ya know that I was from Nintendo to a
Super Nintendo an owner of my cousin's
house and we play Sega well
yeah when they were rub it in my face
they're like oh yeah you can play demos
on Sega
you know
what's a demo you know and that was
something saying ahead
I want from that since Super Nintendo -
oh man I was going to Toys R Us almost
every day playing Mario's a
dream but giving kids didn't even let
enough touch for free like it was the
arcade
in my grave again my grandfather
so actually someone stole my bike and
brakes didn't even work
the next day to play again you know I
mean hey bike you know oh no I mean I
was I actually got a third of the way
through the game and I'm like man I'm
playing too much now you know what toys
but it was free so
man you know Gamecube I mean you saying
start from the beginning so I'm just
trying to think my way through this yeah
I took a break from gaming for a while
which which is actually good but I mean
like well you know what got me back into
as Resident Evil 4 I mean that's Maddox
loving you right now because resonable
for as much as it was like that was
where I felt like after that resin he
went down there like big-time but Rose
knew before I actually really liked it a
lot of people for a really hardcore
ignore hardcore than I am about that
early Resident Evil's didn't like it as
much I'll I thought I had a perfect
balance
but I was up to you know 1:00 2:00 in
the morning playing that game with all
the weight off sometimes I
you know it's funny yo Rick we we talk
to everybody and certain games innately
make you do certain things and residue
will light off you want to get the
atmosphere the I'll be honest in the
room going everybody says the same thing
and it doesn't matter if you and Mexico
shout out to my man
you and the Bronx you where you are
everybody then turn that light off and
play resonate let's get the hell on
these zone
mention - I did have some PC days like I
was doing on the first PC gaming head
was resin evil one
resident ones classic man how to play
Rainbow six man because on my PC but it
would freeze any time I started
multiplayer
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
if the rig wasn't up to snuff
if those minimum requirements
would turn me off of my PC we're done
here we're done
I'm glad you mention it and I'll get not
to start a console war drama of PC
elitist vs. console peasant drama but
I'm glad you said that because only from
the standpoint from a lot of console
lovers these are the kind of experiences
sometimes that get us frustrated with PC
as a gaming platform because there's
always some type of variable to shout
out the lower BG I believe he made a
statement you know recently tweet that
was pretty wet pretty vile which was
kind of like to the effect that you know
everyone tries to make it seem you know
it's so easy just to set up and
sometimes there are different variables
whether it be the drivers or something
else that can affect the experience and
you know for sometimes people just want
to just come home sort lauric and just
like pop in the game or the days and
just boot up right
PCs complicated but it's always like
it's always on you
you you voice your concern like you know
PC every time I try to do this it does
this I do that it gets turned around
from you know PC needs to be fixed and
these kind of issues to that's a you
problem
so there's a I'm glad you brought that I
learn it because it's funny because a
we have heard that or the case so so he
said after that that he came back now
let me ask you about I know you
mentioned the big Nintendo areas and a
lot the chat is loved when you said
getting q you said Super Nintendo chat
was definitely on now didn't he and 64
[Laughter]
64 was the toys-r-us I'm sorry I did
definitely purchase 64 so your credit I
didn't say that I I got the 64 I just
will say about I'll sing my GameCube I'm
right there but no - before I obviously
had Mario
you know Yoshi games and whatever else
64 had to offer that I can't but with
pilot wings and all that right yeah it
was a whole new era man that 64 man so
yeah I was pretty
pretty it cuts a video game history
gotta respect that they tend to love
that was really really cool so long yeah
man I was getting to like the industry
aspect so it's like we know you as the
game gamers gamer and um as far as like
now what was that Pat that kind of led
you to actually getting the war students
becoming community management and the
second part that question is obviously
you know we know that their prog based
so as a US Representative like what
challenges did that face so let's start
from that journey into war horse yeah so
I mean as a kid I used to get you know I
was excited man when I even got my
Nintendo Power every month then I'd be
wait you know that mailman I know I
would be like running out there like
and then you know when III first started
I saw as a kid I'm gonna find a way go
to e3 you know one time I'm going yeah
that's how it all that to where I'm
about to go with this you know well I
actually some people know some don't but
I also on the
work for Verizon a couple days a week
about every nice
shout out the file to child through the
files
and 5g is gonna be sick that's good you
know but I I've been there for a while
now so I only have to work a little bit
with them do well there so it opened up
other opportunities and one of the
things that happen is when we were
promoting Windows Phones I had to take a
course on this website Microsoft expert
zone you guys might heard of expert zone
yes I guard like a retailer partner you
know they do all sorts of stuff with
like all Microsoft products of course
yes
you know Xbox whatever and so it was
when we had learned about Windows Phones
there was this contest I noticed man on
the website and it was like first 300
people get
passes to go see Microsoft the Xbox
press conference at e3
a three hour party after on a Wednesday
so for three hours you'd get to go to
the Xbox booth just experts own members
mmm
so I'm like and it was like first come
first serve so I'm like you know type in
you filled out the form and like I got
to put a co-worker that could come with
me and we just so happen to win we were
part of even 300 people cuz there's
thousands of people on their website so
yeah I got this email my junk mail of
all things I took my junk mail all shout
out to Tekken s spam so you ain't
missing
so anyway when we went it was it was
like
I'm just gonna be honest with you man
like we you know you fake it's you make
it you know hey you got your listen we
all started somewhere in am Tony there's
the the more people you talk to in the
industry you'd be surprised how they got
where they did and then um so I'm just
beating as the kids say as the cool kids
actually secure cool kid say I'm keeping
it 100 100 baby keep it 100 in the run
little
[Music]
you know but I mean so I we went and I'm
like we are going to find a way to go in
and III I don't care we're going in and
listen I'm just just being honest we uh
we were definitely felt like an always
sneak and as far as the help
and you know now I understand more how
the industry works looks like I don't
know how I would approach it the same
way not that I would change anything but
uh so we're going to the security guard
in my
there like you know you know you guys
don't have any three badge and we didn't
know we didn't know if we actually had
some access with the same you know
whatever well my buddy had this badge
from Verizon he goes with Verizon mm-hmm
the house
you know they said oh just go go go go
go so where we were and
[Music]
just ii doubted himself what is verizon
doing here I'm not asking just going
what happened to it - my man's like
those animes were the door just lights
up
whenever and then um we just started
talking to people in the industry I
remember Amanda skating and I wish I
could remember the game to give a shout
out to these guys it was a game that
looked like it was something new on the
Xbox was an indie game and you could
play a good amount before it came out
and it was like
it was an action
mostly action game and there was a
little bit of magic dar man I wish I
could remember I'm not even describing
it very well
whatever it was it made it impression
man yeah and I talked to the developer
I'm like my point was about talking to
developers I started talking to
developers starting to see how cool it
was to work in the industry and then on
Twitter that expert zone said first 10
people to respond to this get tickets to
the rest of he's right
[Music]
battle frogs Iselle says was a castle
crashing they trying to figured out that
gaming game I don't think that ever
actually made it to the finish and I
just wish I could remember there was
like some cool boss battles it was like
it was not it was a 2d good we'll get
closer to two you know I can remember
you know Louis very come back to your
little town so you got in you guys won
now the e3
so you want to get to go to the press
conference you finessed your way in the
door
what's crazy when we went to the
Microsoft press conference just being
honest were like okay we need to meet
people because I know how to get to the
other ones yeah sure enough man we
there's a guy in line and we talked to
him name is Skyler were friends of this
day I mean we just got to be buddy-buddy
and then he's like we're walking with
him towards a press conference not a nor
he's like yeah these guys with me
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about
and then that was when they first
announced the Battlefront the first one
so we're like you know crazy man and it
was just a teaser but okay so each year
we were like we are gonna find a way to
go every year and now skipping ahead a
little bit I know I could keep going man
but like of it so on Twitter I mean you
know what this is being honest - so I I
loved horse Kingdom Come deliverance
before I knew the guys my brother showed
me it showed me a trailer of the game
and I'm like I'm just waiting for magic
[Laughter]
on the oil is realism is cool with magic
I
haven't being ruined because whenever I
play a game I don't care if I will
suffer I will not use magic if I can
help it now on the wall you spell like
attic right head
I'm like you know William Wallace all
these guys are even struggling in neo
because I refuse to use magic
brother I made it through the whole game
and I died so much man let me be honest
with you like I I try to be careful the
words that come out of my mouth I'm not
careful
everything under the Sun just about
everything under the Sun I was so bad
you know you ever play gets the end of
the boss battle in like you also knew
freeze
one or two more hits and then I freeze
up and he killed him
which is things on a on sinner and I
fought one of them and the second one
was still alive and I'm sitting there
like running around it because she's
like a lightning creature and she's
lightning at you and I'm thinking myself
the whole time like if I could hit like
I had no more potions I had no more
spirit yes I had no more fireballs I was
like if I could hit one time it's a rat
for like ten minutes
just kidding like one hit and it didn't
even matter if I did I wasn't in danger
I was running I hit her one time and
it was crazy because I got you know and
my brother he actually said before I met
these guys you go to e3 you need to find
out more about this game for me so
but as I actually was found warhorse
studios on twitter and at the time the
company was mostly speaking in Czech
right oh I actually unfollowed I didn't
know what they were saying
I just you know and sure enough man on
Twitter those are retweet from a III
Party list because I wanted it on you
know meet people who worked in the
industry or whatever and go to this e3
parties and make connections and they
retweeted a tweet and it was at warhorse
studios it was their tweet was once to
set up a party and he's at a pub I just
responded right away to Saddam and I'll
do it other no doubt Cosmo says shout
out to google translate
translate tweet it's the best diverse
when working with these guys but bottom
line is just being honest there was how
everything started and I'm FM I never I
love them yes with you too I don't I
don't drink I just don't I don't like I
don't like to
thank you
know
I'm talking to Toby our PR manager to
Toby has to be them good dude general
marketing manager now
like several days a week you know
because it take your ticket very serious
recess to the community in life they
gave me a chance man like and what
happened is you know normally when
you're furthest there studio or any
company you work with you gotta you
gotta be there yeah and I give all the
credit in the world and I appreciate
Toby so much because he's the one that
says you know what um you know it's like
six months later after like certain I
even talk about my wife and I Sarah oh
wow you were really considering it Wow
I'll tell you this
she did consider a little bit like we
homeschool our kids so she actually
looked like all the rules and every
thought out to that selects a loofa even
looking that's that's what say yes so I
just but then Toby's like listen I'm
you're working with us one way or
another and then they came up with this
position for me and I'm telling you that
with my passion already for the game and
then being able to do this they this
helps reach a much larger audience not
that they could
Tony this is why the company warhorse
sure we've had you know ups and downs
we're always working to make the game
better and we've never shied from that
but you know like like they're always
trying to do the best thing that they
can to reach out and I love them for
that man like I'm there I've been here
now with one more studios for
man it'll be three years I think it
Marty isn't it right yeah
and you know working in the industry
it's actually hard to work for a company
for a long time because there's a lot of
changes yes or there's maybe there isn't
gonna be new game for a while maybe
there's only one game I mean what're you
gonna do it like there is no like and
like I'm unlike with these guys as long
as they have me you know I don't see
that you know not we got a good relation
to this gonna be that way because we
have we still more content coming and
then it's because you know our fans were
gonna have a future and I love you know
to walk into that point when we got into
packs and you was the first interview
that we had right now as we're packing
up to get in that we said we're gonna
give our t-shirts now we had a certain
amount of t-shirts to hand out and
kognito was like yeah how are we gonna
give our t-shirts yuzawa barometer yes
alright because when we got to you um
the level of passion that you show for
that game was above and beyond and it
didn't come off phony it wasn't canned
it wasn't no script it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't it was just straight-up real
you understand I said this man is an
iron Lord this man right here exactly
what we're talking about alright so
write down like you'll get this gif you
instantly
get this shirt get this man a shirt
we went to other of the developers and
used the barometer not many people got
that sure you're like many people got
that shirt
all right we would be one developer
except this time I'll let you go in the
second attic we went to one developer
right there right adjacent to him we
went to another developer
that guy showed more passion about his
project than this guy and he got his
shirt and the other guy looked over like
what
like if I knew that I would have worked
harder but you didn't because you
you didn't have that passion work you
were that if Rick level is that he's
preaching right now all right because
you were our barometer when it came to
speaking to the devs and we wanted to
see people not only that knew about
their day but was passionate about that
game and shout out the walls too because
you set up was dope you guys even had
like Joe guys running around in like you
know Knight armor and it was just so
cool and it fit us and we like you know
we love this studio we love this game
they have one of the best community
managers out here and that became the
barometer while we made our rounds on
pax that hey if the guy has that passion
as Lord Ric did he go get that shirt
certified then it wasn't happen
you guys had that meeting when I was on
the plane didn't you yes yeah you have
been when like a lady well I loved it
because when I was there man you went
like right into an interview so there
was no time to be fake
he was ready he was ready bad that
that's what you were to see man it's
nothing faked up in 40 when their base
rather to get attic I'll let you go and
if the Good Book said man be ready in
season and out of season
it's like I said you know I think people
that a lot of passion for their game
ends up you know overall hope in the
game aspect of our life we were talking
before the podcast started the I can't
remember same the individual from the
game award it's like you could see hip
passionate his voice that he was talking
about his game and people remembered
that
[Music]
the game that we started having so much
fun with about the Prison Break and
standpoint to you know especially the
the dev that we talk to about sinner you
know he really has about the game
and you can sense that like I expected
III is really bad III like I'm tired of
going up there you don't want to get a
little bit inside on a game and it's
just someone that was hired to sit there
and
work to just hold up that whole despot
this wasn't the case absolutely well get
back on track real quick but um so yeah
so like for those living under a rock
lord make like or just not familiar with
Kingdom Come deliverance like tell us
about the origin the kcd the Kickstarter
pitched like to have you based in that
authentic time period with the human
simulation in the combat the risen the
realism and then finally the decision
that in my opinion make a CD a cult
classic which was not to include that
magic or the Dragons in the vein or
Skyrim or whatever so let's start from
that beginning like tell me about so for
anyone that doesn't know about Kingdom
Come delivers to this point tell us
about that man yeah so
damn Barbara is our creative director
who also was the creative director
behind Matthew one and two you have
heart and clima who's our executive
producer he wrote the scripts for the
RPG game dragons that are back at most
at the 90s oh
he went down a couple big night XCOM but
a couple big alien games Holly's forget
alien mm you have phone something
without a defense like
it was another one but eat another one
then also worked on operation flashpoint
nice Oh
Victor
like he's trying to say my last name
like easy people say lasagna you know
[Laughter]
you know so like I mean that's what you
get with Kingdom Come deliverance you
get a you get through a story-driven
game of mafia right then you get realism
of operation flashpoint so you know it's
like those two I guess you could say had
a little baby yes and by the way Sabrina
and you know source girls those two
super kcg fans are amazing yes I salute
to Sabrina and Chad yes suitable for
them in the chat right now reppin hard
so you know they they gathered together
in the pub and I guess in the Czech
Republic that's for all their good ideas
only
something hang is crazy
[Laughter]
based on medieval you know European
history is you know closer to their
region to write and something that
actually has never been done before
right the game takes place in the early
15th century or where the Holy Roman
Empire was really going on you know you
always think of Rome and Italy is like
man that this is what shaped a lot of
things that came to happen was what
happened in Bohemia you know which is
modern-day Czech Republic right
so it's a our our game isn't you open
world you know RPG very story driven
first-person and
you know there's over four hours of
cutscenes in the game only so many of
those unlock based on the choices you
make but it's yes it supports a conflict
you know you know so you have
that this big civil war conflict between
two kings and they're actually you know
they're brothers right they're actually
uh half brothers and one of ducks the
other you know and we keep go on and on
what happens by year Henry's to help
tries to help restore the balance he's
not going to be some like Lord or a king
or like you know some like like real big
hierarchy whatever he's just a man he's
dumb man
it doesn't know how to do anything in
hat you have to help it is always quite
hungry
[Laughter]
certain things in the drinkin what's up
with the drinking in his sleep and then
to save him
so I didn't learn I didn't know that if
if I didn't like align myself with that
old war chief to teach me sword
techniques then you know because he
teaches you that they're special Perry
and that unblockable stuff like if ya if
you if you didn't sit there all the time
with this guy practicing because you go
automatically don't align yourself with
him you do your own thing
totally miss this one part that guy if
you don't get him your skills is trash
like really bad it's me so oh go ahead
I wanted to ask you about that
specifically like did y'all knew
if we didn't seek this dude out that you
were going to just die a lot later on
right oh of course but here's the thing
like even in the beginning when you
start you you know you see Miller right
when you know causes a little
distraction
sir robot helps you escape and
everything and your you're in the middle
of physx house and all that and and even
he teaches you if you so choose you can
learn how to lockpick enough a
pickpocket with him so don't try and
learn these things or like even with
kept them or not we can't actually
funnel you in because remember that's
even part of the the quest yes right
what'll you into that but if you and I'm
telling you I saw several people they're
like I don't need that let's get on to
the fun stuff
if you like Dark Souls it's like that
sort of thing like me then do it because
I'm I know I make it pretty ticked off
sometimes they'll get me wrong
I like that stuff yeah this part of the
game is like training we try to really
immerse you in the game and I'm just
very I don't think I think it's fair to
say I'm not even trying to be cocky or I
meant that all
games that are this immersive in that
respect Talk That Talk oh and I'm glad
you I want a double two because not to
cut you Laurie it's just that alright I
think what makes the game why has such a
cold found my people love us so much is
because be honest did that genre is kind
of oversaturated with the dragons the
magic you know that kind of a deal so
when you see something based on realism
and like you said Henry's just this
normal guy right and he's got to eat
he's not asleep he's got to Train try to
kill a rabbit with that boat
[Applause]
dropping short of the rabbit
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely just like when I see
something like that it's like it's out
of your hands out in the chat it's
almost like a life simulator this is how
I this hourly it's like a little bit of
Skyrim with a little bit of like Mass
Effect dialogue choices were with this
life simulator aspect all combined into
one into like one of my favorite time
periods of all the battle system is like
so unorthodox it kind of reminds me of
like a more in-depth version of for
honor
like quarterly got three positions this
gay got like five oh yeah
and this new comes up and he starts like
pushing his chest out man I'm well
alright let's go and I play normally I'd
be cocky not saying you've got to get
this business but
the last point I'll make it I'll give it
to back to Rick is that for old-school
heads solve and King may remember like
you almost get you yes Kings feel yeah a
little bit of Bushido blade with the
combat is like a lot of feels that I got
from her but good go a little Rick man
we love this thing no no it's good it's
good but you know going back to like the
Kickstarter was dungeons and no dragons
nicer you know and obviously we stressed
some and no magic and because that
that's something you just really don't
haven't seen and especially when we
based it off history not that 100% it's
a video game we're gonna cheat I mean
it's not a one-to-one ratio in the game
for that but the towns of cities were
actually those were there and in the
castles we had actually like like you
know taking photorealistic images and
done or did our research we even have a
full time destroy on our team to make
sure that these were reconstructed to
how they would actually have looked back
oh
but with a Kickstarter I mean we went to
every investor you can imagine and just
no one was really willing to pull the
trigger they just thought you know
unless we have magic or actual dragons
in there and you're not gonna make it
but Dan Dan's a very bold man and I like
brief and and I applaud him on sticking
to the integrity of the game instead
even as far as they have a slogan guns
into no dragons you know and um I'm Tony
the the the goal was I think a little
over 300,000 euros for the Kickstarter
because we had one investor in Czech
Republic there was one she has just one
and that was if that wasn't gonna happen
it wasn't that you wouldn't we would be
here Wow but not only that the
Kickstarter we had to prove it doing
over three hundred thousand euros in
2014 we did we get over I think 1
million
thousand it was amazing yes we're the
third most successful Kickstarter in
2014
so that's what you know and so really
obviously is it's a combined effort from
the fans our investor in the team you
know
it it's great you guys already know we
sold over a million copies we didn't
except though has to be that quick again
Frank man we didn't know how quick it
was gonna kick off we were nervous -
it's our first game yeah absolutely
kognito said people want to play those
type of games but a lot of people are
tired of the magic stuff the mythology
pudding game so someone comes there's
like you know we got something for you
the crazy thing too is is you know we
talked about the really evil combat
setting and everything but I think the
best part of the game this is just my
opinion is and I could say a lot of
things because the music is amazing like
any good game has to have good music
soluta all your boy Adam spork aright
Adam spork and Yalu good guys
unbelievable
yeah and but I love the the way you can
do the quests all the different ways and
all that so we Toby and I would talk
about every time representing the game
different ways to do this but there's
even more than that yeah even with the
new dlc it's like you can do that you
can go into trains you know you got it
you got this like a dice competition
game now we raise the points like like
there's some times you actually go up to
6,000 points instead of two but in the
now this went to form in the tournament
and all these guys you have cheating
dice and you
know what fine you know what screw you
pal I'm gonna go and I want to steal
your dice that night or I'm just gonna
kill you you know like so the
conflict is poisoning them poison in the
food
one or more people our two people two or
more people I was getting murdered
so you know what I got guaranteed ev2 I
got poison in the cup
do a drag it out and fly-half them off
the mountain
no I'm glad you bet you you know saying
the successful in Steve's I was just
actually gonna lead into so I'm very
proud obviously to see kc d represented
well at the essential and european game
awards aka the Kega that's what I'm
calling it the Kega
there you go guys you guys actually got
nominated in multiple categories and um
but you also came home the best
narrative award so I want you to talk
about that experience as well as the kcd
going platinum on stephen schap as the
top seller for 2018 yeah as far as best
narrative goes i mean it's it's really
an honor because we really stress or a
story driven game I mean there's no
doubt that we stress that there's gonna
be a game is going to be lots of
cutscenes there's going to be twists and
turns there's going to be things that
are happening that are meant to happen
in the story and we you know and there's
only as we know it right there's one
ending to the game like Henry's
character the way it develops the with
the things that happened with this
family it's it's it's really quite I
don't know of corny but legendary man
it's like very intimate it is intimate
man in like from the very beginning
there's no messing around with what's
going on in in the story and then and
then there's twists and turns right now
well mini spoiler
okay
there's a lot of leaving it yeah though
those don't give that up because I had
to suffer through a lot of things seven
seven hours in and I'm like I'm starting
to
my my my stride I'm starting to hit my
stride
I didn't have any cheats I'm sorry
addict but honestly if you don't know me
by now I'm a dude that gotta do it I
don't look at a video to figure it out I
don't I don't I don't care about that
stuff I gotta do it Murray no one that
said that I
that if we go back in the archives you
said that you've looked stuff up for
stuff before
gamefaqs yeah that's some bully
different
game faxes game fax is something at me
assault I don't even know how sovereign
found it but um it was like oh you don't
know how to get this part in Metroid I'm
like nah man I've been doing this for
hours and I don't understand how to do
this alright so go to game specs you go
to game effects you put you in the
naming of the game and then you look and
it'll tell you all right so you go to
the left corridor and you jump up there
it don't give you like it wasn't a video
it just told you we're
going do
what you do is you go watch somebody
play the game
[Laughter]
I'm sure you
success and obviously with the best dad
of willing eyes the team feel what's the
energy at the studio right now and you
know what the thing is it's like we we
were aesthetic I still remember when I
was there because you guys know I've
said live in the u.s. I live in upstate
New York and I'm like I am absolutely
going down there for release I'm going
down there
or you know now that's say going down
you know here but um I'm gonna be there
to celebrate with the team but let me
tell you what happened so of course
we're looking at reviews everybody does
if they're a Liars if they don't we all
care about you know what people say
about
your game and but let me tell you
something there was so much work to do
that we celebrated for like oh that's
great you know cuz you know the
Metacritic scores between 75 and 80 or
something like that we were so we were
very happy but we had work to do man so
it's like you know then then a DLC comes
out and we have work to do we got a got
to make it better we gotta fix some bugs
or whatever so it's like the energy the
energy is high but it's like what would
it's kind of like if you you know a team
that wins a Super Bowl not saying like
we won the Super Bowl or something but
when you released a game you think you
won the Super Bowl I mean
okay but that was
last year so we got some work to do now
it's a whole new season so for us it's
like okay the games out that's great
it's sound it's all the makeups great
fantastic very happy but we have work to
do we've content so it'll come up I
still gotta you know I gotta keep in
touch with my fans there's stuff to do
so there's a lot of work going on
so that's the energy madness meet we
have work to do we want to make our game
better and better and better we want to
optimize and do what we have to do so
we're keeping on truckin then no that's
good to see man good to hear and like I
said definitely proud when I saw that
because again I think the game doesn't
get enough credit narrative lis and
especially with cinematics I mean just
from the open in the game again not to
spoil too much but you know the tone is
set very early the stakes and I remember
what that was one of the things that
kind of really drew me in you know me
you guys real like you say you have so
much narrative so many cutscenes and
things of that nature so I like to see
that you guys took that seriously and
you know but you know cuz a lot but you
don't eat the casual thing to say oh
it's a skyrim clone this has nothing to
do
when I was talking about the game the
first thing I said it gives me like a
Skyrim self a better story yeah the
first like the story is crazy
Susan alex
is the black plague in the game if it is
or is it gonna be at a DLC
no reason walking around I'm like
murder in the
[Laughter]
link to our to our road map so you can
see the DLC you know I'm saying no doubt
let's get that roam and
try again I can't I can't do a link
just post something real quick and he'll
make you an admin yeah what would you
suppose something real quick I get you
boom boom right mmhmm
kind of graded out that's all right I'll
uh I'll make just post something to the
chat I'll actually take it oh okay
we'll get you that cuz they they what
they want that road map they want that
let me give you the modern race I'm
looking for Marcus all right now
but you should be able to do it now
all right don't worry we'll take it
alright whatever did that hang out and
I'll have addict take care of it so
there's no problem but um yeah we're
gonna get that road map to you Lord you
know saying that's a fact so
put a hangout radical take care of it oh
let's get those lights up
shadows let's move it what's up man yes
it's coming look it's cover Louis bear
with us but um yeah me so while we
waiting on that I want to talk about
obviously this you know the first with
the first major DLC from the ashes under
the studios Bell uh
to kind of bring us up to speed now with
the latest DLC and you guys picked like
the longest DLC name and history of DLC
names
yeah I ever got corrected or the
abbreviation that it was so long I was
like oh yeah that's great so is the
amorous adventures of the bold sir hands
captain
about how it differs from the ashes DLC
and also why like lots of realm a
stepped away from kcd be interested to
dash back into the realm of Bohemia so
sell us Lord Rick let's talk about this
new DLC Azkaban yeah so the boat
adventures are the event Wow
also Hans cape on there you go yeah
there we go but Sir Hans is is your boy
in the beginning of the game well
actually if you guys recall he doesn't
like you he's no bility you're not right
and they don't like each other very much
right and after Sir Hamish who's running
the show then Hans wants to run the show
right because he's entitled to he
doesn't like do it all he doesn't like
how you're kind of like not necess IMing
up the ranks but have a little more
respect and there's some reasons why see
what I don't try this stuff away too
much yeah he doesn't like that he
doesn't like that he's gonna even
captain Bernard who trained you doesn't
like you in the beginning yep you got to
earn their respect I'm interesting in
life respect has to be
like your life is like man why don't you
trust this if you haven't earned my
respect mm-hmm and I'll trust you you
know
anyway
so this okay so throughout the story
Hans and and Henry starts it you know
they get more you know respect right
bring the game to get a little fist
fight they have a little competition
aren't really those combat you know and
all that stuff and even in this DLC you
still see Hans clearly wants to let you
know he's the Lord right exactly well
but um it's really it's a lot it's
really funny man like this humor in the
in this DLC and he falls in love with um
a blacksmith's daughter go figure
blacksmith
right and but the thing is is blacksmith
you know it's less lower class status
bang you know so he falls in love with
károly
that is exactly how you
berries yeah yeah so and you but he
wants you to help him woo her over and
he says it's like the latest fashion in
France like the stealth kind of love you
know a
more you know I try to speak a little
bit friendship four years from say but I
a lot of it would be a problem from say
which means I don't understand French
you know so he wants you to
get he has a letter he wants you to
sneak into her room
so that she can take a look at and start
to get wooed by
and also she he has he had his a great
grandmother's necklace very beautiful
necklace but he lost him he was gambling
yes and he wants you to go get it back
and when you find out and again this is
something that we've already kind of
talked about something that says spoiler
but the guy who wanted from from Hans he
was murder mmm Oh once you find that out
and you need to go and find the guy who
was responsible or whatever then you
have to because you need you want to get
this necklace for her and so you need to
go into this camp and it's kind of like
secluded and it's not really well-known
so you have to talk to the right people
right guy or whatever to find this place
but also um to the guy that has been
murdered you kind of and roundabout way
they actually don't
man I just want to give it up you know
what a fraud bail
Ibis can't do some investigation and
stuff and there's like a dice
competition thing and like like I told
like we're talking about earlier and
stuff and it's really kind of cool
because
with any deal see your any game you can
blow through it you can go through it
real quick and with our game there's a
lot of different ways you can do things
and I like how I have different save
points I'll actually go back and try a
different way because then you get to
see how it would happen it different way
because sometimes you have a different
cutscene
so when you're in that camp there's just
so many different ways you can approach
it take part of the dice tournament but
even if you lose maybe you can talk find
out who did this or that and talk this
person into listen I need this now if
you buy it off here maybe I'll go steal
that maybe I'll just kill the whole camp
you can try it hard right
but then there's other things and then
like when Hans you know
sneaks into a carolina's room like you
have to kind of like distract her father
and stuff who's outside was all this
noise and I almost got nothing but it
almost gives me like Romeo and Juliet
vibes but a comedy on some levels to
wit up with Henry trying to help hands
get his his macking up
the thing is like it's there's a lot of
because like and then you get to see
your boy and if you played through the
game a little bit you the the Charlatans
crazy because he's like selling these
potions and said you know they'll do all
sorts of things which we have to know in
the game is no magic but he makes it
like it's magic he like sells this then
he just like playing the game
West begins from Red Dead all these fake
potions and like all the medieval power
[Laughter]
and that's we got to give this like
thing to allure heard this like function
for Hans man in life it's just you know
then he gives you a recipe and all this
panic
you know it's just fun it's a lot of
funny not and I always recommend when
you play our DLCs but you play the story
sometimes even you know save get a
certain safe spot because you know there
are times to where you can fail to do
something if you fail you could cut
yourself short yes yeah you you could
get in the print when you rebuild and
pretty saw this man you can screw all
that up and you can start to stop it man
that like we're done you and guess what
you're not the bailiff anymore and it's
it doesn't mean you can't like
necessarily go there or something but it
means you're not going to be the
bailiffs you're not gonna be the one
building and it's like so that's why
it's good to have different save points
absolutely absolutely that yeah that's
the part about it's really cool it to me
it's a nice it's a refreshing take you
know because obviously we've had the the
other DLC which is from the ashes and
that that's the vibe I got from that
with that in the hardcore mode was also
like more for the advanced player who
had all this money who had you know kind
of like beat the game and they had
didn't have all the things to do and I
felt that kind of satisfied that whereas
this is like a definitely a change of
pace and for me personally I want to
talk about is that tournament mo you
know say this because we noticed there's
some loads out here that really got good
at the kcd fighting system so tell us
about that let's get the cell on with
that part so what's cause in
from the ashes DLC it was the first time
you could actually like practice more so
with like a particular
with with a person but you could
practice and hone your skills in just a
bad track for a minute the one nice
thing is you guys still haven't played
the game in my opinion I actually think
you have a better experience from the
beginning with rebuilding because when
you lean though after you you take it
down so to speak
with Sir Robert yes you you are there's
things you can do there that you're
building growing because you're making
money there you can also you know you
train hone your skills if you've already
be in the game you've probably honed a
lot of your skills so you can actually
get maybe a little more out of it going
into the tournament you've experienced a
little bit of this training but
tournament takes it on a whole nother
level it's all about your skill because
you know the weapons are chosen and the
armor and stuff so then it's not going
to be unbalanced like absolutely fine
like with long swords or whatever it is
so that you know it's going to be more
comes down to the player skill and in a
tournament you can win their heinous who
actually award you with some like really
good armor or a really good weapon or
whatever if you win and
it's really cool man because the
tournament even has a couple quests and
there's certain things that might affect
a little bit of this here a little bit
of that what's cool too you can play the
game if you will yes in this tournament
is something that people like we kind of
showed off before the game came out and
I'm glad you come to fruition in the
fact that it's free you know what I mean
absolutely
absolutely got a salute on that man and
I'm glad you said that because I said
you know what because so much new
content has come out and it's been a
while I mean I said let me just start a
new playthrough you know so this way you
get all that stuff you're the chat got
to start with
because at the end of the day it's like
you know you want that fresh coat of
paint everything combined into one
seamless experience and also to LEDs we
put in that dad DLC roadmap in the chest
you guys can also see what else is
coming coming up cuz it looks like some
real cool stuff and one last thing I
want to ask you was just about on patch
1.7 so we know that's just been released
now I got to keep it true with you Lord
Rick in the realm of the Lord it's a
full disclosure
as ambitious it is basic as this gaming
right there was some very tough bugs and
glitches that kind of prevented progress
at times Lock clicking included in the
beginning so I need to
talk to the Lord talk to talk to a guy
like my guy Lord Fonzarelli who loves
your game right he was a huge fan at
launch but he just couldn't take it
anymore ask after certain point you
don't say so he loved the idea but he
stepped away so what could we say now at
patch 1.7 - could we say to him to kind
of bring him back to make him give kcd
that second shot talk to us well I mean
I mean we went from you know we started
at patch one point you know one 11.1
whatever now we're at 1.7 so it's come
it's come a long way
even when I I played on
just about all platforms with the game
of course and for presentations I played
it at home obviously my own little
testing whatever on Steam and I played I
want to do my own playthrough without
like any
like this like this was the untouched
one the one I didn't test on I wanted to
go into this naked like everyone else in
a way like I want to do my own place
through the way I want rather than a
certain way because of testing this and
that yeah
even way back when you know at least I
myself had experienced any bugs that
were causing me to click you know then
prevented me from playing any further
however there was for for some people
there definitely was patch 1.7 now we're
actually we actually started to spend
time even and more like optimizing it so
even as textures and Poppins and things
there's there's something that's like
gone it just come a long way I mean
there's no denying that you know for a
game this size we had we have soft work
and so if you you know from coming back
then to now well we've actually totally
revamped I don't know about totally but
we've revamped a lock-picking it
actually made it easier when it first
came out on consoles
well also we even with the saving we
added a save and exit so
make it easier to save the game because
when you save an exit that save that
save goes away when you start again so
you don't write save over and over again
we wanted you to try and live with
decisions I'm not gonna lie to just
interrupt your real quick I when I found
out you needed a drink alcohol to save
that was a controversial decision no but
I won't be honest I did respect the in
the beginning because it's like it made
every safe meaningful
when to see how it says on the item
after it says you know you need to drink
this I think it said potion I can't
remember spend it or not
but it's
this is an Halla drink I'm like oh my
god
they really
so you know because again like you know
this isn't there are some auto stays
when you get certain parts of the game
and actually as we had pastor we added a
couple more of auto safe but what we
didn't want to change the tone of the
game and yet at the same time we found
what I believe was a very good balance
and actually from working with the
community over the years we've we've had
a real happy balance in the community
was like you know just please whatever
you do don't don't change that the tone
or the pace of the game and we certainly
did we just made more like it was very
reasonable they had a save and exit
feature to where if you have to get
going you know you don't have to worry
about like especially if you have a
family or a child jumping in another app
and shutting that game down because they
jumped into another game or you know
something like that yeah but as far as
like all the other stuff in and we're
still working on the game to make it
better but bottom line is like if you
look at the patch notes you'll see that
the the things that we had you know
worked on in the passive not only come a
long way but it's just mmm you can play
from A to B there you know you're gonna
be able to play for me to be whoever's
frustrating the past right now
especially if you're worried about clock
picking and another thing it still comes
out do you have to try and train no and
once you start to hone your craft so if
you get towards the end of the game you
become super heavy you become like Hulk
in lock-picking honestly as you progress
it actually gets pretty simple because
of level up now the ones that said easy
or even even hard you're just used to it
and as we remember this perks even
I'm glad you said that and I want to
give a shout out to because um I feel I
mean I'm running around the X and it
looks fantastic to me like this
cinematic look so I could only imagine
you know what what King is experiencing
on PC and stuff like that and and like
you said the first thing I notice all
off the back was the optimization and
I'm like okay they went back in here
because definitely things are falling
much smoother looks better you know I'm
saying and a lot of that stuff is that
all the older stuff was cleaned out so
I'm beat the Lord fast personally it was
a huge fan of your game tell me to get
out there and get that new DLC
1.7 in Xbox enhancements is out here in
these streets
absolutely very humbled and proud to see
man rocking that I'll be sure to pax
really humbling to have you man and any
more announcements as we put the road
map out there in the chat for therefore
the Lord's you know any more
announcements on the way for a DLC plan
for the future well I mean you know
we're still working on optimizing and
all that stuff we're always gonna work
on making the game better experience but
we you know there's no doubt if you see
in the roadmap that the next DLC in line
is Vanda bastards oh really really
really really looking forward to that
one and I you know it's definitely gonna
be very unique and different from what
you've seen in the first two DLCs and
but you know we take it one day at a
time yeah we've given you guys like our
vision and our vision is Kingdom Come
deliverance and to make it better and
bigger and better and and after you know
Banda Masters then we have another
special one that we talked about all the
way in the Kickstarter that the backers
are gonna get for free and that one's
called a woman's lot
no you know there's actually going to be
an interesting you know little thing
that you know playable character as well
I'm not gonna give away who she is party
never speculation and we'll see but you
know she's left and not you know there's
more in store we still have
jeez even a documentary an official
documentary for us that we're also going
to be you know we're working on that too
so a lot of exciting stuff and I really
appreciate the fan support and hanging
in there with us and we're always there
man like you know I love working with
the community at love you guys we got
Christian our European community
management we tag-team it up and I'm
touching those guys everyday on skype
man just just like their very next door
to me so
we're gonna be here for a while and
that's what's up a great to see to
continue to pull it this game is
definitely one of the surprises of 2018
and just to see like I said you got
started from a Kickstarter to see the
growth and now it's like in almost in
that triple-a space and just continually
can to get that support these are these
are the success stories we like because
a lot of times in the gaming industry we
don't see stuff like that you you hear
about stuff getting canceled studios
falling apart you know so continue to
support this game with Lords will always
support this it's in our realm right up
our alley I love I guess we had to show
you love that so before before we get
you out of it as far as the kcd stuff um
I gotta ask Lord Rick the question we
ask every Lord at the round table I need
those top five video games or franchises
of all time
whoo that's a haul
and I might give you king by I have you
know kcd a bit so you have to report
back to your bosses and go get trouble
let's go I'm gonna put any by love it
let's go I'm gonna have to do like
series otherwise Dark Souls in there
every time
I gotta go number one with myself this
Elvis series
90%
passionate about Zelda is the only my
only complaint and breath and while it's
a big one as much as I love it with
Helen temples go yeah what's your
problem
those are some of the best things and
you you want to put in little shrines
[Laughter]
definitely a lot of people or anybody
saw we got Zelda I will always buy sell
and all the way back to mr. Miyamoto um
comedy by the way that's all in this
story so he's a man so um and again this
is just the kiddin me man but I gotta go
next
tough I'm probably gonna just be very
easy on this with super mario man
because
I love it I gotta go Dark Souls oh
all right that's three that's three I'm
probably actually if I'm going in order
I'm gonna go Ghost Recon series above I
shall ooh I love Ghost Recon if I was
single and I
probably would have tried to compete at
the highest levels you know whoa did try
you know we weren't that great we were a
top 50 team on
MLG back in the day that wasn't actually
that good in my opinion there was
hundreds of teams but you know we tried
but I was like a married man
man talk
kids right all right you can't beat
level 600 you got kids you gotta take it
down you gotta take advanced recon dark
souls seldom Mario one last one to
finish it off
one last one and again it doesn't it's
something that personally affected Judah
as far as your gaming history
one through four
there's a lot of like you know what's my
card that's not forgotten honorable
mentions man I have a lot of honor give
me an honorable mention um let's see
here and again I gotta think about this
one cuz I now remember when I was kid
man I never played Sega I never really
played ps4 games so I missed out on the
God of War and stuff you know that you
know they're really good Uncharted stuff
even though I have the latest ones
honorable mention is emoji Rainbow six
series Far Cry series nice
what else I'm gonna try and think here
about some other that I just
automatically get you know read that
Redemption of course
go back Tecmo Super Bowl
and Street Fighter man the old street
fighters now hey how's
another crazy so just the
disjoint that I've seen somebody gets
stabbed
[Laughter]
dude that was a tremendous list man
absolutely we got to get it to show
hopefully you can still rock with us for
a little bit I know you got things you
gotta do so if you gotta leave you gotta
leave out completely already but we got
a couple more topics roll out so let's
get the show poppin last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question if Microsoft
Project X cloud proves to live to
actually live up to expectation with
minimal latency and a legitimate
seamless console streaming experience
would you consider it as an option for
your remote gaming meet the winner at
62% of the vote was yes I would at least
consider Project X cloud as an
attractive option group coming in at
second place at 34% was the no
traditional console will always be great
at greater than streaming group and
coming in at a shallow better place and
only 4% was the what's up with that
claw which think about that
listen I'm going to play if you can tell
me you're telling me that I can take my
xbox wherever it is and you mentioned
this when we spoke about it yeah that
that's which is kind of in the bushes
I'm gonna play my xbox games wherever
and it's gonna be a reasonable facsimile
of what I have in my house yes yes yes
yes
the smoke announce we have a new poll
coming at the end so let's get into
these topics and blaze through large
sovereign
Rockstar and working conditions what's
going on all right so when I first
brought up this uh this topic I got a
lotta pushback
please well and it just seemed like you
know it wasn't I'm sorry I gave you
pushback it's a beautiful topic it is
and when I say a beautiful topic is it
has a lot of points to talk on but it's
not a beautiful situation that's
happening
which is why I'm approaching it from a
different perspective than most people
would think so bear with me while I get
there right let's go so um so recently
dan Houser one of the cofounders of
rockstar didn't issue with vulture way
talked about it basically there was a
visit to rockstar in New York City they
talked about the development already at
redemption and whatnot and at one point
during the interview he mentioned that
they were working something like a
hundred plus hours a week to get things
done so obviously
that sort of raises eyebrows when you
talk about stuff like that because
rockstar has been in the news in the
past for alleged you know bad working
conditions and and crunch conditions at
the studio this happened with the
release around the release of the
original Red Dead right so dan Houser
made this statement and uh you know
people all over the internet Jason let
me I'm point directly adjacent Schreyer
indicated that he had more information
from anonymous sources and in all
likelihood there would be some sort of
expose type thing that he would release
uh soon he had that freestyle cooking
speaking about speaking about this sort
of stuff and in den Houser
uncharacteristically came back out and
said wait there was some
misunderstanding about how I worded that
stuff I meant the writing team like the
four people with the primaries on the
writing team for you know X amount of
time we really go hard to finish up
everything that needs to be done at the
studio to be very clear like no one is
forced to work ot um it's you know
people if you're super passionate you
want to stay here we don't stop you but
at we don't force you to do anything
which is weird because they don't ever
talk about that stuff all right so what
after that then there was more
discussion about well there's gonna be
more stuff coming out indicating that
that isn't necessarily true or it is
true for some people um and not others
um and then another uncharacteristic
thing that they did was they sort of let
loose sort of their rules for um social
media interaction with their employees
and sort of told them hey go out there
and tell us how great it is to tell
everybody how great it is to work for us
like this is not true mmm well so at the
end of the day this is the way I feel
about it right and we've talked about
this in past episodes with other
companies and this sort of crunch stuff
I say this
does the gaming industry on some sort of
level need some sort of regulation where
this stuff doesn't happen especially for
first like in new incoming employees
people fresh out of college absolutely
now that said I'm gonna tell you this
from my perspective I'm a grown man
let's go I will get top man talk
I don't care how much I'm getting paid I
don't care how much of a dream position
it is for me if I am in a position where
I am not happy with what I'm doing
despite it being the stuff I'm so
passionate about and if I feel I'm being
disrespected and abused I'm gone mmm no
one gun to anyone's head to do this
stuff if you're still
it is it is baffling to me that this
stuff obviously there's certain checks
and balances and regulations that need
to be put in place absolutely but at the
same time it is your choice to continue
to to work under those conditions right
I am listen if I feel disrespected I
have to look at myself in the mirror
every day I'm not gonna take that I'm
moving on and that's it until I find
something that doesn't make me feel that
way right so that that's that's my
feeling on that sort of stuff now what I
want to talk about in terms of rock star
quickly and then we can comment on the
eye on everything was the fact that
listen there are very few entities or
people in the world that can get away
with such extreme hubris and light and
and always back it up you know like
avoid mayweather every time he talks
listen man I got nothing to say to you
you back it up every time you come out I
have no beef with you well Conor
McGregor his he's in the bushes
[Laughter]
rocks over the years earn that sort of
reputation where every time they come
out they're dropping Ethan its crap
every time they come out and but it
seems like it they've got a little more
sort of full of themselves where they're
sort of the narrative that they try to
control around the launch of the game is
sort of crazy like this whole thing
about the media blackout the social the
social
aspects of not letting their like their
employees talk about certain stuff
online
on this because
I'm talking about you can't talk online
for the fear that you
see that's one thing right now
directly that are you gonna laugh at
right they also came out saying that hey
mom and pop shops fu
and this is why the car this is why the
topic here because mr. Lee didn't get
your game where we tell
the hook right now
[Music]
I already have it digitally pre-ordered
so then we're getting to purchase
I'm not having
I told you in the past they're two ways
I work out a game Church of Satan
[Applause]
balls
[Laughter]
let me just say two things
I'm getting this but
okay one aspect of one of my companies
is you can't disclose who you are
protecting all right talk to your
friends about it it talk to your family
about it you can't talk to anybody about
it because a lot of times these people
is here under Pizzuti own names and
doing things that they frankly they
sometimes they don't even want to be
known that they're in New York you know
so um those those situations can't be
divulged so when they put a blanket over
the company and you can't talk that's
what you signed up for you knew going in
and if you found out later on it you
said well I'm such of a blabbermouth
that I needs to be on social media I
need to talk about your game that you
don't needs to be here oh there's
something that you have to you know
reconcile within yourself but I
understand your true point is he shut
down
Ricky I love Rick I wouldn't start with
you because on the ground and we all
know obviously all of you guys yourself
Lord Toby Lord Adam spork I got a chance
to meet you guys um you know you guys
work extremely hard and I'm fantastic at
your jobs you know I mean so what I want
to know is like obviously we know
warhorse you know the high level quality
product product and all the things it
takes to deliver so I'm curious about
your take on this and the temperature of
what we're gonna say is crunch culture
right
you know it's coming you know I get you
in trouble I'm saying but I just want to
say like as a game studio revs up closer
to release as Kingdom Come was revving
up right like what's your take on this
coming in as a person on the other side
some things that you learn very quickly
in social media this is not so first I'm
not gonna answer anything that has to do
anything with warhorse or just just
don't know anything on social media will
always get blown out of proportion
correct doesn't matter what it is it's
really easy if if you if you get
emotional about things easy in life
you're gonna just go with whatever said
on social media so if it looks bad
you're gonna think it's bad and you're
immediately gonna make judgments and
accusations and that's - but that's a
shame really it's a shame that's not
being a man or a woman that's just it's
just being driven out of immaturity
because we like to join we just like
good
in it in its trends we just believe it
to be true that's too bad that's too bad
but I don't know now getting back to
this when of course you put in more
hours towards release I mean there's
there's and there's so many things I'm
not even gonna get into as reasons why
mmm you do know but here's the thing one
thing I love with what we do is that
there's no micromanagement there's
there's asks and we work together again
done right and sometimes it takes a
little longer but i all i can say is man
is like i don't know about $100 worth
weeks or whatever yeah the thing is is
unless I talk to someone directly I
don't care who says it unless there may
be pulling direct quotes and maybe a
couple quotes not just one right because
it's easy to take those out of context
mm-hmm I don't let it bother me like
trying to say right on this is not about
right or wrong this or not this is just
about media right and so I could teach
calmly as you finish I'll let you finish
it's about sometimes a little added
extra drama perfect time for this
because they can go off because it's the
right time to talk about it that is true
that is my main gripe with this entire
thing right I generally when it comes to
Jason's fryer and the stuff that he
talks about I'm all in because he's easy
he's always he tells the truth what I
don't like is the timing of this you
know if these if these are issues that
Rockstar these will have always been
issues that Rockstar what what is the
need to bring it up right now when it's
gonna take away he goes that the most
traffic right for that home exactly so
if nobody it's true and that feels very
gross that's what kind of gross I
want to I want to ask you to solve don't
ask no rectus to but what about in Jason
tries defense did also a
comment or write about the actual
positive comments that were coming on
when rockstar got in front of it right
and then these guys to employees to make
statements and the majority of those
employee you said hey they never
experienced that you know so what what
do you say to that with a him allowing
that information to be released and be
the also thought of like you know you
know I see this this banter on the
internet which is kind of right well you
know what those guys are paid to say
that or you know are they under duress
you know that kind of big to say like
what what's your what say you to those
kind of
mean Jason is Jason I don't I don't know
business at a know him as a person so I
know I don't I don't even want to go
there because I don't I don't really
know man I don't really know like I
don't even try and spend too much time
on there because at the end of the day
for me the the way I see it is
you know whether this is going on I know
look no matter what job you do if you
put in a hundred hours it's not good
there's there's no way around it is your
god
no
that's just um I think we could agree
that this just it's not gonna take the
best toll on you but right at the same
time at the same time if you talk to old
school folks
who used to work really hard on extra
hearts with their families when it was a
lot more difficult
that's some of the things they did and
they were proud to do that so I'm not
gonna go in and make judgments cuz I
don't know these people I honest I don't
have any relations with with anybody
that works on Red Dead Redemption maybe
I did who am I to say anything about it
so all I'm gonna say is I'm a
garbage man alright
in the morning
[Laughter]
he comes over he could take for shower
I'm like brother
when you're doing recycling no sir
we did over a thousand stops and you're
going in this restaurant man I'm just
Tony there was maggots thousands of them
on the ground Wow
yeah oh no I really come from
but the point is is this like I try not
to really formulate more not because I'm
not there I don't know the circumstance
what it's what if someone did work 100
hours a week did they did they want to
and if they did and if they did then
it's just for the hell of a paycheck
Rick that's one hell of a paycheck
all the time talking about my crazy
workweek and again that's all by choice
and when I don't feel like doing it I
don't feel like doing it I don't do it
it's just the grossest stuff around the
stuff is that it's happening now because
it's taken away from it maybe Red Dead
is a game that anything out of rock
stars maybe is a game that's kind of
immune to this and there's gonna so you
know gangbusters regardless but the fact
that all this negative stuff is coming
out the week of the
that's what I'm saying if you remember
Jason Shriver has said that it's dis
still something in the pipeline that's
probably coming up this week closer to
the game's release
the reason why I say okay I'll give you
two scenarios right now you can have one
of those people to have one of those
horrible jobs and when that one hour
feels like 10 hours right right or you
can have one of those jobs that is so
lit that his soul is the bomb that is
this time to go home already dead paper
job so let's say he's after oh my is it
time to go home already I listen I got
another five to six hours I mean let's
continue working on this because we is
making real progress and we're almost
done so who's to say that person or
those people or that group didn't do
that didn't have a blast doing it and
probably set it in the image oh we did a
hundred hour work week
eventually they're gonna this won't be
an issue in fact everyone we talk about
how good the game is
one of the things I want to point out is
you know I've talked to a lot of devs in
the industry you know crutch town does
happen a lot like especially you know
when they have to meet a certain
milestone for their publishers and stuff
like that is you know I mean I've been
told there's there's a couple things
when it comes to it
usually after the game's launch they get
they get a little bit of downtime and I
don't know if that happens with Rockstar
I'd assume because they met them a
they've got to make a lot of money off
this game
but you know there's a couple things
going into it I don't necessarily I do
think there what they did say there were
people working 100 hours a week there I
would say anything that's a lot of your
higher-ups the people that's overseeing
an entire department mm-hmm because
they're trying to make sure everything
is connected dots there so I would say
that they're working a lot of hours now
I'm not saying that they're working a
hundred hours every week right you know
they might have had a weak word they had
a meet of criteria they worked a hundred
hours that week and then probably one a
couple weeks working you your standard
4050 hours in that in that district
first I want to say he's like we don't
really he didn't even say that he all he
said was we have people working a
hundred hours a week to make sure this
game comes out when you say it like that
it seems like we have a hundred
passionate people working to make sure
this game comes out how it's supposed to
and you know we live in a day of Twitter
and Twitter everything gets leaked if it
was a lot of misusing management there
and people will do huge that would have
been on Twitter
in some way shape or form you have all
those people and you're managing all
these people if there was a lot of
people over there that was not filling
how they were being worked it would have
been on Twitter it would have been on
neogaf there would have been some kind
of leak it wouldn't be at the very end
now you starting to hear about it right
why who says that they didn't work a
couple hundred hours week and then now
they're about to take three weeks off
right yeah let me jump in because this
this is definitely a polarizing topic
and I definitely I'm in agreement with
all the lords here all of you made great
points like Rick as well and I think
it's interesting because obviously the
employees the news that's coming out is
definitely polarizing right I want to
shout out I had a great conversation
with the four guys recorders guys I
talked to Inferno clowns and assassin
those guys on their show and I guess my
perspective is a little different as an
IT guy because I can always be for
myself right but in my field it is
outright verbalized at point of hire
like what is expected and that there
will be various crunch periods
throughout the year whether it's like
either some type of migration or
whenever we're doing like any type of
cloud infrastructure changes you know so
at that point to me the issue comes down
to whether it's paid ot compas of
compensation involved or not now if
there's if it's clear that there's no
paid ot for these crunch periods then at
that point i'm with lord King myself
like it's a becomes a personal decision
to remain with that job right because
once you sign up I don't think you can
have it both ways and complain you don't
say you knew coming in again if that's
the case right so my thing is you know
if you're upset and you're like hey this
day working me too hard and I didn't
expect this level you know I'm saying
then it's time to put that resume up
to excessive you know I'm saying so from
all these accounts and it seems that
they're mix everyone's experience seems
to be a little different and I'm saying
the good the only good thing about all
this is that it does bring the light if
there are companies that you know kind
of any shady practices then of course
that's gonna be put on the light but I
do do agree with solving a sense that
you know the timing is interesting I
have to be honest the timings
interesting and then the latest thing is
obviously they just came out and said
that our rockstars QA studio said that
now they had a meeting and that overtime
is officially now optional after workers
said they felt it felt mandatory so
that's what I got or
probably when as a lot of people felt
like you know it's I'm sure it was
optional I think state law aren't they
in New York or something like that
they're in the states aren't they it has
to be off you know unless they're on
salary
who's boycotting red dead
nobody not a soul people have said
this stuff doesn't apply to all the
studios since they have various studios
around in the world like expectations
are different in different places right
so not everyone's experience is the same
some people may feel like it's more
mandatory than others
and at different levels of Management
also like higher and ajmer and opposed
to like you know ground level workers
and whatnot all I know is regardless at
the if they really did work than 100
hours for a little bit to make sure this
game car because I mean we've seen the
game it's a very mask am highly detailed
it would not surprise me one bit if
these people I'd work 100 hours to make
that possible in the game at a time
like Rick saying like how do you expect
this to happen with that level of
100 hours that you work don't worry I'm
gonna buy your game and I'm pretty sure
that millions of other people are going
to buy your game and I'm pretty sure
while you are on vacation and I'm back
at work slaving and playing your game
you gonna give me that shoutout to say
salute thank you but a hundred hours
that you work that week I'm not gonna
shed a tear because there's a person
this week that didn't work one hour that
will definitely work that hundred hours
so and you know not start they I don't
think we've ever heard any kind of
negativity thing when it comes to them I
do think that if they did work people
like that like consistently not like one
week consistently then you know Rockstar
probably should hand them a little check
after the game comes out you know that's
neither here there we don't know what's
going on know what's going on what's
going on these people could be working
forty hours in the right or worked a
hundred from home we don't know that
that's perfectly plausible the writer
could have been working a hundred hours
from home and everyone else was working
a standard I don't think they got that
kind of content that kind of quality
again it would not surprise me if they
work in average of 60 hours a week
let's get out of here because we got
Rick's got his Giants coming ups we
getting it about him man but um last one
will fly through it is days gone
[Music]
because actually this subject
so I'm going to
wait a couple months wasn't it or at
least
you got the bug oh
my thing is when does the hyperbole
start or where does it end because they
said that the game was a plan right it
wasn't looking good
because of the competition
got delayed because Sony hasn't been
pushing that game if you haven't notice
the Sony hasn't been pushing that game
like it has been pushing all these other
girls of the shema and all these other
games have been getting top billing
I'm just saying like it was inevitable
the writing was on the wall and they
wanna uh I I'm personally looking
forward to this game I've really liked
that whole horde of zombie type of thing
running for your life and you could push
somebody and make the zombies eat them I
think that it's incredible to me I like
that whole aspect of it but you know
people are making such a big deal out of
delays and when when has Adelaide been
bad the game was better off for it you
understand so this one bring to the
table another top-shelf game that I feel
is a top-shelf game and suffer to delay
and do is deem it as bad or do we deem
good lord Rick we'll get you real
quicker than that much time but what do
you feel about just delays in general
knobs days gone see again this is
there's no right or wrong answer because
it really depends on what the situation
is but I'll tell you delay is I mean
we've had our own delays our warm-ups
I'll say when we delays because we just
want to make it better we're and I know
it's tough it's tough because you want a
game to come out sooner but again this
day and age I told you guys before the
podcast started on my backlog so big I
got touched or something
from being a standpoint in the industry
is there a lot of emphasis behind delays
like is there a lot of backlash if you
have to get a delay or is it just
something that you want to avoid but
it's not necessarily a bad thing if you
do because we only really know from like
you know we don't see what happens
behind when a delay happens is there a
lot of repercussions for it here's the
thing you care about your fans you never
really want to delay in that respects
because you feel like you know you've
let the fans down a little bit you know
I know that's a hard one but at the same
time we know why is because we need more
time to make it better it's the truth
you mean you try to have
this and that but see you know y'all so
we also have to realize you know there's
there's weather how big your studio is -
they also plays a factor and you know
obviously it's not just like one studio
here their games get too late all the
time read that Redemption you know
so it's about making a game better
that's just this just the bottom line
it's Bobby giving you
so let me let me jump in on this too
because um I'm gonna greet me with all
you know the Lord he is well shout the
braaap in the chat you know the salute
Lee yeah I mean I'm probably like like
what can probably one is still there I
love the premise of like you know the
game itself actually just talk about the
game day's going itself like little Sons
of Anarchy looking character you know
zombies you know enemies can be used
against each other with you know the
hordes and stuff like that so
it's just a smart call right just get
away from the madness that is February
because we got a lot of titles coming
out right at their honor this year I
think I've ever seen at the beginning
it's in say so let them get away from
that you know the shine is now on April
let them put the proper polish on it and
like I said it's like you know delays to
me are always good the only time the
only I know where the crackdown thing is
going yeah I know what you go with that
I don't think they are the same but the
only time I struggle with the ladies is
if it's like now we don't like delay
three no I'm saying we all ate three
delay
is ever going to come out I'm saying at
that point I start saying it's an April
Fool's joke yeah like at that point it's
like okay there's still guys waiting you
know saying just like okay I don't know
but what it's like something like this
and you know shelter I mean call of duty
right there's just this year look looks
what's happening you know they saw what
was coming we're red dead and we go move
this thing like
there's interesting about this game for
me is that they gave it a date right a
lot of times like Rockstar you rocks
don't give you a season right and you
know
you're not getting your you're getting
at least one or two delays you're not
getting so they do that gives you a year
first
citizen with a game yeah
what's interesting is that they gave it
a date and they're moving it and it's
true for me I think the game is
essentially done but it's smart to get
out of that madness you don't have Adam
coming out that day you still have for
me the Dark Horse of that day is Metro
Exodus yes but you know I got a child to
loss Sam got a chance with him to touch
that behind the scenes and not that that
thing looks
the most important thing is the health
of that game and overall can use the
most polished it possibly can because I
saw you and moving it regardless of the
reason was the right thing to do because
if you look compared to be like if God
of War is coming out that day that's not
in the game that's moving his spider-man
is coming out that day that's not the
game that's moving so obviously there's
more there's more work to be done on
this game to get a new where they needed
to get it so you know I'm all for it no
absolutely my absolute Lord act looking
you want to finish this out I'm good
okay cool
with any delay like Lord Rick said you
know back in the days we had like one or
two games for the year and you know we
were happy with that and we were starved
to the next game came out we made that a
million dollar seller
a one-armed so now in this day and age
we have back loads like he said yeah
backlog of tetris
I
tend to push games off I don't buy games
initially anymore I've learned because
I'll buy a game at 60 bucks and when I
get a time to play it is actually $30
around the plate and it's gone I coulda
saved myself 30 bucks all right so um
nowadays delays are good that this is
what I feel delays are good it gives the
time for the company to put the shine on
that game and this is a game that I was
really looking more to on PlayStation so
I wanted to have it's spider-man moment
it's God of War moment in time and it's
fun that you know PlayStation guys
gravitate toward I wanted to trend on
Twitter I wanted to be topics and
talking points I don't want it to be
lost in the shuffle and between the
anthem or this game in that game
everything every developer deserves to
have that spotlight on them at least for
two to three weeks so you know let this
game get it shine and I felt the delays
are good for the industry so you know we
all got a backlog if you don't have a
backlog you're not playing ads and like
law at law sovereign lauric say what was
the famous quote loss of my motto what
is it a delayed or a bag a bad game is
bad forever a delayed or something like
that a delaying game is whatever I
forgot it
so that was the
section right there King so um you know
with the poll so in reference to both
the recent positive and negative
testimonials regarding crunch culture
conditions at Rockstar Studios which
statement closely represents your
sentiments regarding game release
deadline environments the choices are a
no one is forced to do anything in
regards to employment crunch comes with
the territory be some companies will
coerce you into extreme hours crunch is
wrong see crunch is only an issue if
there no ot or compensation or D I don't
care if Red Dead don't release on time
I'm gonna crunch the studio
[Laughter]
Lord Rick leg easy an absolute pleasure
to have you the Lord where can define
people find you and what else do you
have going on in the world of Kingdom
Come deliverance where can they find me
they can find me on Twitter Rick 5 to 9
to wish the same on Steam and the same
problem won't accept your friend request
no offense
kcd in the forums because otherwise DMS
are crazy you know that's ok they're
open on Twitter you can do me any time
there
and it's always Rick five to ninety two
I'm the Xbox same thing and eventually
PlayStation I got changed my tag makes
lies but you know I kind of already
mentioned about what's going on with
kingdom come
we're working on a quick hot fix now and
then we we also have like said more DLC
this coming out I'll resolve
DeMarco that DLC roadmap yes if you
follow our studios on Twitter just add
water studios keep up with all the later
stuff as well mm-hmm but again hit me up
read five to ninety I love talking
anybody anytime the Lord of community
manages super passionate it's always a
pleasure to see you out there making the
rounds promoting the game and just to
see the success of this game and it's
just really warms a law it's hard we we
love the journey we'd love to see you
guys continuing to put great content out
and shout out to the Studios for having
the longest DLC name in the history of
the LCS
the amorous adventures of the bold sir
hey
[Laughter]
Rick Lord addict wicked define people
finds what you got going on you can find
me on Twitter at Lourdes at the IOP you
can find me on youtube at gaming at it
I'll probably releasing some videos this
week I don't know yet depends on how I
feel when I get off work tonight I'm
gonna go ahead and put it in the comment
section
so definitely go follow them on Twitter
yeah yes Twitter I appreciate you for
coming on Rick it's been a pleasure
talking to you and you see you guys next
week
absolutely Lourdes sovereign
people else you got going on you can
find me at Lourdes I've I hope you on
Twitter and being sovereign on yes Xbox
Live mom or Rick thank you for coming
through man much appreciated
to meet you at pax hopefully next year
that would be a different story um and
just guys pick up this game because we
we you know we this there's all this
talk around Red Dead about how it's
gonna move the open world genre forward
and you guys don't get enough credit for
what you did with your game and already
taking steps in that direction in terms
of the systems in this game in terms of
the narrative everything the minutia
that you guys managed to to make
interesting in a game is something
that's never really been seen in an
open-world game or an RPG before um you
guys don't get enough credit for that it
is absolutely
hot of watermark when it comes to RPG so
every size pick this game up please he's
absolutely Lord King we can a fab you
find what you're going on all right
first of all first and foremost um I'm
bowing to Lord Rick oh because
you set my expectations when we got two
packs you know my expectations for every
developer or every project manager
or every voice of the company from there
only like if that level of passion isn't
there I'm not engaged
and you keep that same energy it was not
funny with you cuz when we when we met
up later on same energy same in a
different place same energy facts you
understand so you are respected
honorable member of the realm and um is
a pleasure to know you alright no
thank you I want y'all understand this
is this is the new spot and nothing no
disrespect to the old spot um we still
cool is no red vs. blue
you know cuz you know miss miss Kleinman
everybody is picking side there's no
side stay subscribed over there
subscribe over here hit those mics over
there hit those lakes over here you
understand um we're at a point where we
have to grow in certain directions on
combat talk would have been going on
last night it didn't go on last night
because I knew Andrade was gonna beat
player - ah - um he's supposed to fight
our Billie Joe Saunders test positive
bad stuff um now we have kos popping up
your understand with that is later the
t-shirts is popping in the store hit the
link below or make sure you go to the
store now it's not just t-shirts there
guys only can get it twisted you got
leggings for ladies you got socks cuz
it's cold right now with the time is
here the hoodies let's go in cities huh
and we got those mugs to drink your
cocoa your coffee
let's show that iron Lord our love
listen listen let's get that out there
mo we have big things coming
in the
castle
I
think we need a serious serious
understand listen Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
follow likes subscribe let's make this
thing happen oh
the sweepstakes - um red dead giveaway
I'm putting it in
exactly
system to somebody this year I want you
to get a system if you don't have Xbox
one EXO you'll have a PlayStation Pro or
you don't have a switch and that's the
system that you want
y'all have a blessed day let's watch
this football if that's what you do or
go out and have fun with the kids
exactly yay again shout out the Lord
King for that obviously the links for
description for the ILP storefront and
like I said all the latest royal swag
it's up in there again not your shirts
winter is coming we got the hoodies we
got two sweaters we got more stuff
coming more colorways please check that
out and of course do not miss our red
dead giveaway this for the five days
left please get in there follow the
instructions you get a chance to win a
digital copy of red dead the game of
your choice the platform of your choice
so please check that out right there and
obviously like I said a little reckon
absolute pleasure to have him in the
realm talking please salute Kingdom Come
deliverance it's a fantastic game you're
really really doing yourself with these
servers haven't checked it out again
flashpoint 35 is currently up on the
channel with POTUS YouTube gaming zone
he's doing well out here and that's our
passion project so if you want the
latest in destiny check that out and of
course the patreon is up we're going to
do a couple of edits I'm working with
myself on that so stay tuned for that
and if anybody has anything else left to
say if not everybody enjoy your Sunday
peace